imagine you wake up one day to discover
that artificial intelligence has become
Superior to human intelligence does this
mean that we won't be able to control
our destiny
will this mean the end of the human
species
you should not have facial recognition
as a technology in the wiring we want to
build smarter machines because then we
can all play
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
on May 11 1997 I received a phone call
from a friend
he told me I should be watching the last
and decisive game between world champion
Gary Kasparov and deep blue
deep blue is not a person but a computer
I was so excited because Kasparov had
already beaten deep blue a year prior in
1996.
and it was time for the supercomputer's
revenge
honestly at the time I was rooting for
the computer
to me deep blue itself was astonishing
proof of human intelligence
the best computer human scientists had
made beat the greatest chess player I
thought they were all accomplishments of
human intellect now I wonder if the
future achievements of machines
still be considered ours
to build intelligent machines that are
really like humans we need to crack the
problem of common sense in the next 50
or 100 years we will have ai systems
which are instantly distinguishable from
humans
[Music]
foreign
s evolve and interfere more and more
with our daily lives
people are starting to get afraid they
are terrified at the thought of
artificial intelligence surpassing human
intellect
could this actually happen
what would happen to humanity if it did
will we still exist
I am thrilled to be witnessing the rise
of artificial intelligence A.I
the idea of having a virtual entity that
can think with you learn from you or
offer you a perspective different from
your own
is exciting
will artificial intelligence become our
virtual friend
or should we worry about the
technological singularity
the hypothetical point in time at which
technological growth becomes radically
faster and uncontrollable
resulting in irreversible and
unforeseeable changes to human
civilization
will this be possible in the future
dilip George an AI and Neuroscience
researcher who studies the relationship
between machines in the human brain may
have an answer
delete George is on screen
hi dilip thank you for taking the time
to talk to me
considering the complexity of human
intelligence
do you think that artificial
intelligence one day could really
imitate it the answer is absolutely yes
because finally we are also machines
um you know humans are machines we can
understand the mechanism by which it
works just like we can understand how
hard Works how a kidney Works how lungs
work brain is an organ yes definitely a
lot more complex than a hard kidney but
still it's an organ which which is about
processing information or modeling
information that is coming through the
senses now the question about you know
it is complex how long will it take to
build something like this okay could you
tell me what is singularity okay so uh
there are different schools of thought
on this one I think I
um to me there is no such Singularity
there is no there is no one point um you
know when we achieve human level
intelligence it will have its own limits
it will have its own natural speed
limits on how fast it can acquire data
about the world and how fast it can run
experiments about the world and these
things have natural speed limits in them
do you think one day in the future that
machines will be as efficient as humans
in self-learning what humans have is
something called common sense when
somebody tells you something they are
able to put that in context and
understand humans have this and robots
do not have this right now to build
intelligent machines that are really
like humans we need to crack the problem
of Common Sense and once we do that we
can deal with machines and can be
somewhat confident that oh they are
understanding what we are saying not not
misunderstanding the intent in a future
where humanity and artificial
intelligence can coexist
do you think artificial intelligence
will try to take over artificial
intelligence ultimately is about making
machines that can understand data
understand what's happening around them
and make decisions just like humans can
do if you look at you know what has
happened over the history is that we
always
want machines to do things that we don't
want to do right so uh by having
machines to some of the the routine uh
things that still requires intelligence
to do we will find more things that
humans will enjoy doing and and that
will become our work you know what we
used to call you know this interview
with you know Amar you would call this
work right think of saying that this is
work to somebody 100 years ago right we
want to build smarter machines
because then we can all play that's you
know somebody said this right and and
that's exactly my thing into you know
yeah because this is play this is not
world what we are doing currently is
play and we can enable more people to
play perfect thank you okay awesome
um thank you thank you for your time
the question remains unanswered
is singularity possible and if it is
will it be the end of humanity do you
want me to answer that question
can you answer this question
this is not the right question
listen
do you think you are smarter than me I
should first evaluate your intelligence
would you let me do that no
of course not
I won't
Chess World Champion lost to a machine
with artificial intelligence called Deep
Blue
then what is going to happen to us
check
you got taken by your queen and didn't
realize that the danger came from the
bishop
where was the danger coming from
you know what
I'm not asking the important question
excuse me I've got to work
foreign
question is
why are we afraid of artificial
intelligence when we are the ones
creating it
aren't we the ones who teach it
should we fear ourselves
aren't we supplying AI with all the data
it needs
we make mistakes
so isn't it possible for AI to also make
mistakes and repeat our own biases and
agendas
which are not always Noble or aimed at
helping Humanity
perhaps we should rather fear this
moment
I know Muhammad aurangzeb is one of the
key people sounding the alarm over the
dangers of AI
hi Muhammad how are you doing hiya mark
thank you for having me it's it's my
pleasure to be here can you tell me how
you see the future with artificial
intelligence sure so there are few
possibilities one is that let's say in
the next 50 or 100 years we will have ai
systems which are indistinguishable from
humans and that's going to be the norm
uh so one example is to think about
Chess just the fact that these machines
are able to play better than humans that
has actually revolutionized this game
because now
it's not so initially these machines
were learning from humans but now humans
are learning from these machines
it's actually a hybrid of a human and
machine which taken together constitutes
the best player so it yeah it's my
speculation that more likely than not
it's going to be a collaboration between
Ai and
and humans which is going to lead the
way do you think AI
could be dangerous yeah most certainly
and it's not just it can be dangerous it
has been dangerous uh so a lot of Human
Rights activists and human researchers
in AI they have argued that you should
not have facial recognition as a
technology in the wild
and the reason for that is is that
there's loss of privacy so combining
facial recognition technology so it
gives the governments and large
organizations uh the technology and the
ability to track people over the course
of time at the end of the day AI machine
Learning Systems they are probabilistic
in nature
which means that they are not going to
be right all of the time
for this possibility that you falsely
labeled someone it is going to be
extremely hard a lot of these systems
especially when they're developed in the
west they have less accuracy on people
of color their accuracy for let's say
people of European descent it's more
than 95 but let's say for Brian brown
skin people
or these stations and especially for
Africans
the accuracy is going to be much much
less when you apply these things in
massive scale and especially in context
where the rule of law is not very strong
let's say authoritarian regimes the
possibility of misuse is just great
we understood from Muhammad aurangzeb
that the dangers of artificial
intelligence exist in every aspect of
our daily life
is the solution to revolt against
technology and artificial intelligence
should we isolate them from our lives
reduce our dependence on them
I don't think this is practical we use
AI in our daily lives without noticing
it
when we surf the Internet shop online
and post on social media better yet
maybe the episode you are watching right
now has been suggested by an AI
algorithm
when we apply for a bank loan AI will
decide whether we are eligible for it
when buying a flight ticket online
AI calculates the price we pay
artificial intelligence is everywhere
time it will keep on increasing
during my research I read a study that
mentioned that by 2030
the size of ai's investment would preach
320 billion dollars in the Middle East
so would it be possible to live with AI
without being exposed to unknown risks
can we restrain artificial intelligence
and control it
can we teach it ethics
of course we can
but the question remains which ethics
as Muslims and Arabs our ethics remain
clear whereas the West is leading the
race in developing technology
where do we stand in the war on
artificial intelligence
Dr Muhammad rally
professor of Islam and biomedical ethics
has long studied this matter
is
foreign
[Music]
Italian
figures
[Music]
foreign
we're at the root of the problem
the more we depend on technology that we
haven't produced
the more we are vulnerable to it
we all had a comment removed from our
social media because an AI algorithm
decided it did not fit its code of
conduct
when will we be the ones choosing our
criteria
when will we open the doors to the
Future
open the door
you were to happen
we would at least be ready for it
that's if
if it hasn't already happened
what can I help you with
[Music]
if Singularity as they refer to it were
to happen
would human beings actually feel it
that is a good question
[Music]
thank you